à
[Musique]
après saint pierre c'est au tour de la
commune de cilaos de signer avec le
département la convention dans le cadre
du pacte de solidarité territoriale en
présence de série melchior président du
département
paul técher maire de cilaos et de son
adjointe et vice président du
département claude grondin
ce pacte veut dire quoi tout simplement
que le département et la commune
s'engage à mutualiser leurs moyens
financiers de façon à aménager un peu
plus le territoire
il ya des projets d'investissements
ainsi l'os qui seront financés à 90 %
par le département de la réunion et l'
enveloppe que nous avons voté qu'on a
attribué à la commune de cilaos de façon
équitable
c'est une enveloppe de deux millions
deux cent mille euros cilaos qui est
meurtrie par le passage de ces divers
cyclone si la hausse qui a été souvent
coupés du reste du monde
cette route qui a été dévastée et bien
malgré tout si la hausse est restée
debout
résolument tourné vers l'amélioration de
la situation de ses habitants et le
département accompagne la commune de
cilaos dans ses efforts c'est très
important de le dire et nous sommes
encore leurs côtés dans le développement
agricole
si la convention signée ne prévoit pas
d'action relevant du social les
aménagements prévus au titre de
l'investissement faciliteront la vie des
six indiens et offriront de nouvelles
perspectives économiques
c'est ce que nous rappelle paul técher
maire de cilaos
alors ce pacte qui était signée
aujourd'hui
découle de tout simplement de la volonté
du département d'accompagner l'ensemble
des communes à travers de
l'investissement vers les populations
qui en ont besoin a pour les enclavement
2 pour avoir tout simplement des espaces
de vie plus plus modernes pense pas que
nous nous avons pour quelques deux
millions deux cent mille euros de
travaux financés directement par le
département la collectivité locale s'ils
osent va apporter des 10 % manquants
donc on aura des travaux pour quelques
deux millions six cent mille euros sur
trois projets distincts dont de la
voirie pour à peu près deux millions
d'euros et la différence pour une aire
de jeu
[Musique]